[Music]
hello there
reject nation I'm Greg Alba and I'm Jean
Humphrey we're gonna watch great Grimes
last episode The Walking Dead yeah
that's called what comes after all right
here we go I have only seen up to season
8 episode 1 John was somewhere season 6
I think his rear at Alexandria there
well before all these comments come in
of why are you doing this if you if you
haven't even caught up to the show I'm
gonna do this because a for some reason
even though the Walking Dead isn't as
popular as it used to be it's the show
that I just can't avoid spoilers on
unfortunately it's been a day and I
haven't learned what happens in this
episode yet I was like I'm planning on
was gonna wait till this whole seasons
out and then I'm going to pick up from
where I left off at and then get to this
point I'm like by the time the season's
over I'm gonna get this spoiled for me
somehow
ok Walking Dead's official Twitter
account I might as well just spoil this
for myself already
and when I say this show is constantly
spoil for me I know so much of what goes
on in season 8 already I feel like I
know all the basic bullet points of what
went on I know the main thing is they
defeat me and hand was said of killing
negan they keep him prisoner as they're
rebuilding and everything and Maggie
wants negan dead so I don't really know
the intricate details of what's going on
in season 9 I heard that Gregory did die
they officially killed him oh that
character I know yeah I've heard a bunch
all right so full clarity but I feel
like I know enough to at least
appreciate this episode if it's gonna
get ruined for anyway I might as well
just watch it now before someone spoils
it for me and over at our patreon we do
plenty of TV show reaction watch lungs
because most of time our TV show rations
get blocked in a route which I've put it
up on YouTube on YouTube you can only
show ten minutes and that's usually only
at 20 second intervals at a time I don't
know if you've seen other channels that
do that but it's usually the general
rule of thumb and even sometimes then
your videos still get blocked so only
showing ten minutes here full-length TV
show reaction
this one will be up at our patreon we
got plenty of shows that we cover over
there quite a lot including music video
coverage kyun ace shameless plug
whatever I think what I heard in the
episode before this is something about
Rick landed on he got injured know and
let's lose a hand we'll just figure this
out I'm not sure but I imagine that I'll
be able to fill in a lot of the blank
spaces in my own head for whatever's
going on because I've had so much of
season 8 ruined for me already
whoo all right hit him play people
actually pretty excited I am - so Rick's
my favorite character always has been so
some reason I stuck around I'm pretty
bummed yeah wake up [ __ ]
that's the error
rebar Rick you know the way your hair is
changed you actually look like season
[Music]
just about people finding out oh god I
didn't think I actually missed I don't
know what other way there is Dan is
character but I kind of hope he doesn't
have to die to leave the show that's for
the zombies to read you know this is
this green screen one could argue is my
family
was my baby girl yeah by the way there's
that oh it really has changed
Judith this I like to take credit for
that actually I'm sure others do
finally it's as they said they were
gonna bring him back and I was like how
no sound rig
whoa was your family really Rick she's
into Herschel shoes last before he died
old school Herschel shot this on
location in the main that's really why
they built it so they just have a cheap
set to curtain Georgia story of the
doors
Wow whoo Darryl yeah
and the nurse guy
I lost Shane it was like a damn
nightmare yeah
Oh what she died
yeah
Oh goddamn all of horse killed all the
zombies ha ha ha sounds my show table
right yeah Darrell come on Rick
yeah nobody doesn't fall over like Rick
ride
Hey survived for it had adrenaline going
bud
oh my god hey walk all this Jesus Christ
[Music]
good guess
die an old woman warming your bed
Oh
now wake up huh Oh
[Music]
video game styles blow up those boxes
[Music]
might be too much much way if I gotta
break it
oh this get OH
huh
Oh
yo
shooting
I found
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
why
[Music]
different sword girl shoot xwy girl rip
[Music]
man before rome like bowling and then
it's so embarrassing to like how much I
love ya I was half word I'd be lost or
something like I'm sure like with
additional context everything but to be
kind of felt like I was watching some
cool sequel yeah kick it up for last
left off him like I am missing the bits
of information took place in between but
I thought this was if the episode
quality was on point so the way how all
the other why I officially like stop
watching the show one point that I I
would be fully caught up cuz this is a
great epic from beginning that and I
feel like they may have engineered it
knowing that some people have dropped
off but would definitely come back to
see Rick's last episode yeah and yeah
like I wasn't overly confused either I
was just very impacted most at the time
and I do love episodes like these that
take that sort of dream state you know
I'm dipping in and out of reality and
yeah yeah every time you like dips into
realities
Walker suppose even yeah it's like it's
heart-wrenching but it's also a night
marriages all the way through you know
on a parallel yeah I mean other than
some of the other be stories I forget
trash girls name she's not trash like
her that trash lady you know you got the
B story with Maggie and negan which I
guess is finally wrapped up as well
because that was like the whole issue
that she had at the according to what I
know of the ending of season eight she
did not agree at all with negan being
kept prisoner but I think Carl wanted it
to be that way before he died he left
like a letter for Annie and Rick to say
he's just coming and so like wrapping
that up in conclusion I thought was cool
because for someone who hasn't been
watching the show for a while and then
you see negan he's kind of doing like a
more subtle negan is like he's saying
all the negan things but he's not like
loud and really expression it I got yeah
it's like super subtle and and you get
that inkling that is he just saying
these two say it and then when you see
that he's just broken he's destroyed and
you know he's human again yeah it's
heart-wrenching it makes me wonder what
they're gonna do with his character from
here on out is Jeffrey D mourning in a
really atone for what he's done and he
was gonna shoot it I'm gonna raise you
like my own yeah but in terms of you
know the main essence of this what a
wonderful send-off you're bringing a
full circle with harkening back all the
way to season one right remember how far
we've come and he's back in the hospital
waking up they're escaping on horse in
this whole episode you know half of its
dedicated him like escaping on horse and
of course that scene that you get with
Shane again like Jon Bernthal who it's
cool because since Jon Bernthal left is
shown in the second season but he's
evolved to an even more exceptional
actor like to me when I see Jon Bernthal
in them and anything I'm like excited
he's there I didn't feel that way about
him but he was on The Walking Dead but
there were times when Shane could get a
little much ya know and this I was
wondering they said working
Jon Bernthal looks like how and I
thought this was the terrific scene
between the two of them is one of the
most gripping moments of the episode you
know and I'm glad that it actually
achieved some weight cuz you know a
dream sequence is easy to write in a way
that's like cool and intriguing but not
necessarily weighty yeah and I thought
they justified it well they earned that
moment well it's him wrapping up closure
on things that he's held weight on to
for so long yeah but even taking it back
all the way to Herschel and you forget
that through this whole journey with
Maggie and then Glenn and they have a
kid and then there was Beth at one point
that there must have been some like
heavy weight of guilt and responsibility
of feeling like he failed in some way oh
yeah
and like it's a guy for whom like the
weight of the world must really feel
like it is on his way
yeah so much of the time he's just
trying to keep civilizations together
between Pete and it makes mistakes along
the way it gets emotional and sometimes
makes me crazy mistake I was getting the
impression that he might not die because
there's so much of him teetering on the
afterlife and meeting up with like you
need to wake up your time it's not your
time right now even with Sasha showing
up it was cool how they had the first
couple sequences with Shane were like
okay familiarity of like season one when
they're in the car before it gets shot
and then season two on the farm and the
barn and then you got this one was like
all the dead hey you know what I like we
watched it been lost
yeah I'm even the little detail were the
don'ts crossed out yeah and I love that
they actually came back to that and used
that for an actual thing beyond just a
cool image from the first season you
know it's an iconic image and yet I have
them actually go inside of it and have
this yeah finally open that door yeah
yeah into this strike it's it's I love
that choice because it's almost like at
first nothing could kind of be
satisfying but through the scope of this
weird hallucinatory dream it is like wow
yeah see all those bodies especially for
like a tie-in yeah see the first episode
imagine if you like go back it might be
even kind of cooler when he wants
yeah it's so much better than just the
cafeteria yeah and like having Sascha
come back and bringing it back to like
the themes of the show why to survive
and everything like this really
everything what makes the Walking Dead
to do it it's great - why it's great you
know like the hope why survive the
humanity and then the walkers like it
had it all in one episode in a very
effective way again like that teetering
line of when they all show up to save
the day it's not real but then they show
up like in the distance like where they
would probably really show up yeah
because I was sold first thing oh he I
guess he did die and I thought it was
gonna be like oh they leave it kind of
like open like we don't actually see we
don't see it happen you know I feel like
this episode kind of gives you both
moments because at first you do have
that like oh my god cuz you know cutting
- all the reaction shots and that's
highly suggestive of Rick's definitely
dead so you get that initial crunch and
then I don't know how everybody will
respond to that ending part where he
gets picked up and chop it off I almost
feel like that's sort of an insurance
policy of like he could just exit
forever
or if he wants to come back at any point
you know we can make that happen
maybe when the show finally ends they'll
do it the final season he'll come back
like not like the final episode or close
to you know one of those things yeah
because I heard that they're gonna be
doing some Walking Dead movies for AMC
and they said Rick Grimes will appear in
them ah and I don't know what their
timeline is of those movies if it takes
place like during the when this shows
going on or afterwards or earlier yeah
like I don't know the timeline or why
Rick would be there if it would be
linked to wherever this is going because
honestly like the one part I'm confused
on is this whole thing with the
helicopter being choppered off is that
something that would be made clear to me
if I watch this show or is this still a
mysterious thing knows who's Bosley on
the walkie-talkie yeah it's like is that
supposed to be made clear to me or is
this a mysterious element regardless I
don't think it really matters right now
for the effect to happen because bottom
line is Rick's alive and he's being
flown off what ultimately I guess is a
viewer and as somebody who like yes it's
been a while since I've kept up with the
show but I've always loved
Rick as a character the most out of
everyone and I am happy in a way that he
got such a great episode and isn't
necessarily dead I kind of hoped that
they wouldn't just have him die for some
reason well yeah I mean because he's the
survivor yeah it's weird you want the
show to end and Rick to still be there
but if he has to leave before the show
ends I'm glad I guess that it was kind
of this way I guess it will open up
questions out there like Judith is now
is rocking you know mommy Michonne sword
yeah god she's like Karl's have shown
sordid hey Rick's good yeah super leader
and there's gotta be a little time in
the future right I think so I mean we
should we they showed her earlier in the
episode but I'm not exactly sure if this
has to be later yeah yeah her hair is
like shades darker and she seems a bit
you know bigger yeah it's a little corny
oh yeah yeah as a button I mean you know
cuz we've done this super wrenching
episode and now like if this continued
on I would just have expect her to whip
out the sword that would just be a lot
to get used it looks like they told a
little girl that cool I will concede but
it's fun she's but I'd rather have it be
an ending note of Judith cuz Judith is
you know as is established I forgot what
season they they established it in but
Judith is not Rick's kid it's Laurie and
Shane's kid but you know her dad is Rick
that's cool she goes like Judith Grimes
thanks because even Shane and Rick are
talking about it in the show like that
that's his kid yeah so you know her real
father her father is Rick so to have
this pillow found all these afterlife
sequences he never seen Lori your car we
just killed Karl
I was actually I've been surprised by
that too especially because of the ghost
sequences during season whatever three
or four that was with Lori when she like
appears to him as an apparition oh yeah
that's right after that really wrenching
like Rick has had some very very
wrenching episodes and I and yeah I'm
genuinely shocked perhaps more than Carl
although I don't know maybe if he
actually
we diet I would have expected to see
them but maybe because of that they
didn't show up well my point with this
ending though is I'm cool with the
cheesy ending because it's instills that
hope and that idea of you know like when
Herschel is talking about Maggie strong
and because of all this she'll be even
stronger it says the same thing for
Judith in this scene yeah is that you're
not just cutting - I'm sure she was
heartbroken when she first found out but
showing she turns into someone strong
well it's almost a visual representation
of how fast she is having to grow up now
yeah like who we just watch the entirety
of an episode about her dad going away
Jesus I'd the point his home yeah and
hey man just overall hats off to Andrew
Lincoln because you always get some
really hard to grapple with physically -
yes constantly like a guy that guys
always has to do such physically
demanding [ __ ] on the show and he's
always gonna look like crap doing it but
no Andrew Lincoln to end this off Andrew
Lincoln he was the main reason I kept
watching the show and if this was any
other character how would it have been
like us houses waited yeah Rick I'm like
I don't want to know who I don't want
someone to tell me on the Internet what
happens I know goes well for me soon so
I should just watch this and to watch it
I found this to be very rewarding and he
like I can't imagine so getting good
like again imagine the show remaining
that good without him it's just very
hard for me to imagine that and I wonder
how much longer the show will last
because he was like yes walking that's
always been an ensemble show but there
was always one defining lead and that
was Rick Grimes now that you've taken
that lead out I can this show still
sustained well what they're gonna do is
they're gonna bring in Will Ferrell for
a couple episodes start auditioning
notable address I'm very curious where
this show is gonna take off from here on
out but add your link you know thank you
thank you dedicate cuz if we were
watching this video it was never a lot
has to be said for someone who's on
so for like 10 years and never once half
a stood like I can think of many shows
where characters leave and then you kind
of get to a point where they were like I
can't see why they seem like they
started losing interest and it shows on
screen yeah man Andrew Lincoln never had
that great I did not watch season 8 but
knowing what I've known and why this was
such a big deal is because Andrew
Lincoln was always committed like no
matter what people were saying about the
show yeah he always gave it what it was
like Hugh Jackman Wolverine
yeah like Hugh Jackman never have asked
it Andrew Lincoln never did either he's
to me he is the replaceable thing about
this show I mean there are characters
that I've loved they're really cool
characters really cool ideas and stuff
like that but the one character who
seems like the truest caliber and the
true nucleus that this show can rest
upon is Rick to me yeah you know and
that's something we're like even when I
was getting kind of tired of the show
Rick's stuff always captivates me you
know yeah and yeah just I can't I can't
pull my hat off enough to hit Andrew
Lincoln yeah alright guys well thank you
for watching a whole length TV show
reaction watch long over at our patreon
you can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell and see